there was a major bomb
at movie theaters over the weekend this
would be a movie called to the end it is
a documentary about climate change
featuring Alexandria ocasio-cortez this
movie opened in 120 theaters
do you know how much money the movie
brought in
the movie I've never seen members like
this before I've been in Hollywood I've
worked in the media for a long time
120 theaters had the movie the movie
brought in nine nine thousand six
hundred sixty seven dollars
that is that is no money
it brought in statistically zero money
this was directed by a woman named
Rachel lears
Rachel lears's previous movie uh was on
Netflix it's called knock down the house
it also featured AOC and the way you
knew this movie was a real doozy is if
you go to Rotten Tomatoes to look at
that movie
uh her previous movie had a Critic score
of 99 percent
and rotten tomatoes and an audience
score of 11 percent
so
if if you're especially if you're
talking about political content when a
movie has a high critic score that's
usually a bad sign when a movie has a
low audience score that's usually a bad
sign and when the Delta between the
critics and the audience score is very
very great you know that you have got
just a Primo piece of democrat
propaganda so for this movie the climate
change movie to the end the critic score
is 83 so it's much lower than her
previous AOC movie and as I showed you
man even the critics couldn't totally
get behind this one and there is no
audience score
because no one saw it so there aren't
enough people reviews audience reviews
to to figure that out there's no
appetite for this stuff which is very
encouraging because if you just read the
New York Times and watched CNN and
listened to your teachers in your
liberal schools and listen to the
government you would believe that people
were truly
on the edge of their seats waiting for
the nuclear well not nuclear I guess
solar apocalypse waiting for the
environmental disaster the world is
going to end in five years we're also
but no one cares No One Believes it
nobody cares it is contrived it is a lie
that we are being told
it's a bill of goods that we were being
told I'm not even saying it's a bill of
goods about the environment stuff I mean
I don't even know what the story is
about the environment they said that the
world was Cooling and we were headed for
an ice age and all the top scientists
said it and all the media said it and
they said it was warming and we were
going to all go extinct really soon and
then then they said it's just kind of
doing stuff it's just it's changing
that's going to kill us and they keep
pushing forward the date of when the
world is going to end and so I don't
even know what what the thesis is but
the bill of goods that they are selling
us
is that this is a top issue this is not
a top issue for anybody nobody actually
cares don't be put in that trance okay
they can convince you you who watched
the clip of Donald Trump
you watched him not tell people to
inject themselves with bleach and they
convinced you that he told you to inject
yourself with bleach they can they put
you in a trance it's a form of hypnosis
do not let them do that on these other
issues do not let them do that on
climate change or anything else
I know what you're thinking Michael you
Adonis you just hunk of beautiful
manhood how do you stay looking so fresh
and young and sexy let's just call it
like it is well my friends I'm here to
tell you about genucel skin care I love
these guys I totally trust these guys
I'm very skeptical of a lot of products
designed to keep you looking good and
looking healthy and vibrant I am not
skeptical of genucel skin care I
absolutely adore this product now for
Christmas geniusell's most popular
package is 70 off this includes two
months worth of geniusell's best sellers
plus their hyaluronic acid serum for
free with your purchase I in particular
listen I don't sleep the only things I
ever drink are black coffee and tea and
occasionally some adult beverages I
smoke cigars I stay up late my under eye
bags need all the help that they can get
genius out as a marvelous product for
that and so much else geniusell uses a
proprietary base with clinical levels of
Botanical extracts which come together
to yield amazing results right now go to
genucell.com Knowles use code Knowles
for an additional 10 off your order plus
every order is instantly upgraded to
free express shipping there's
geniusell.com Knowles kwles
geniusell.com Knowles
it's a real it's a real art
this art of deception speaking of the
art of deception
it's going to be one of my best
transitions ever a daily wire is just
breaking some news now we've had an
investigator investigative reporter Bree
Dale on this story for a while now and
it's a it's a really quirky strange
story a one one attorney is describing
this the story as a high-tech Heist and
the broads drugs I encourage you to go
to dailywire.com and read the story
the broad Strokes of it are that people
are stealing they seem to be stealing
the Priceless art from the Vatican
without taking the physical art they're
doing it it would seem
through these corrupt kind of Licensing
deals such that here's how I'll explain
it if I were to put a book together of
all that beautiful art that's that's
owned by the Vatican right now I would
have to license the art from the Vatican
we're from some intermediary company
between me and the Vatican so there was
a company that that wanted to
print some photos of the Vatican art
they go and and they see that the
Vatican art was was listed in this book
and so they they contracted this company
that put out the book it's called
scripta money on
and said okay how do we get the rights
to these these pictures and they said
okay well you've got to do it with this
collaboration that we've got with the
Vatican Museums director Monsignor Paulo
nicolini and so scripta said here don't
worry here's how we'll take care of it
just send us 550
000 and then uh send a Cash Wire in the
amount of eighty two thousand five
hundred dollars cash wire and then we'll
be able to get you this art
now
what our reporters seem to uncover is
that some of this money
looked like it was going directly to the
Monsignor well that's kind of weird and
the Vatican didn't seem to to know that
this was being licensed out and so
anyway it's a whole convoluted story
give it a read I find this sort of thing
very very fascinating because
something somewhere here doesn't make a
lot of sense it would seem to be
some kind of financial corruption
somewhere or gross incompetence but
people are making hundreds and thousands
of dollars probably millions of dollars
off of art that is owned by the Vatican
the Vatican doesn't really seem to be
getting that money it doesn't really
seem to care that it's not and it just
the reason I bring up that story other
than it's kind of an interesting
investigative piece of daily wire the
daily wire uncovered
is to show you how the corruption works
corruption use the Catholic Church as an
example the Catholic Church
scandals
in recent years
what are the scandals it's the sex
scandals of course and they're very
scandalous there's no doubt about that
but when you look into the actual abuse
that the Catholic Church
thank members of the clergy engaged in
you will notice that the Catholic sex
abuse Scandal is no worse no no uh more
widespread in terms of its numbers
then sex abuse among any other religious
group
and so you remember the Southern Baptist
convention had a big one just a few
years ago a big
sex abuse Scandal there have been sex
abuse scandals in the Hasidic Community
they're just in every religious group
through these scandals
furthermore
sex abuse in the Catholic church is much
less prevalent than sex abuse in public
schools so so these edgy atheists and
leftists and secularists they always
want to make snickering jokes about
those pedo priests those little child
diddling priests and they're well okay
if you're going to make those jokes you
should make those jokes much more
frequently about public school teachers
people will be very offended they'll say
that's that's a horrible thing to say
another plenty of great Public School
teachers plenty of great priests the
vast majority of them
doesn't downplay the abuse people really
have been abused by priests and teachers
and everything but it's just so that's
what people focus on right
the much more widespread source of
corruption these subtle little things a
guy maybe paid off this guy and it was
some cash under the table and you better
there was a there was a trend I noticed
in recent years of whenever any anyone
started to look into the Vatican bank
and some of the corruption that was
going on at the Vatican Bank those
people would always find themselves on
the outs maybe they'd get accused of sex
abuse maybe they'd be accused of
something else but it was very hard to
look into the corruption of the Vatican
Bank the rest of the show continues now
Mr Davies tells me we have a magnificent
movie trailer that I have to see I have
to focus all my powers
of cultural perception on this to tell
you what this is about you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]